The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We're going to talk
about inclusion-exclusion which
is a generalization
of what we did
at the end of last lecture,
which was about the sum rule.
Everybody's still
talking I hear.
Anyway, the inclusion-exclusion
principle is very important.
And the best way to explain
this is by using Venn diagrams.
So let's do this.
So what did we do before?
When we worked on
a sum rule, we saw
that if we count the union of
a whole collection of sets that
are all disjoints, then we can
just some all the cardinalities
of each of the members.
So in the case where we have
intersections-- so sets are not
disjoint-- well, if you just
count all the cardinalities--
all of the sizes of
the sets together--
you'll start to do
some double counting.
So with the
inclusion-exclusion principle,
we can actually exactly
compute the cardinality
of the union of sets.
And you will see that
this principle can
be used in plenty of examples,
including some of them that
are on the problem set.
So how does it work?
So let's set take an example
where we just have two sets
and they have an intersection.
So say this is one set which
we call M, and say here
is another set which
we call E. Well, they
have an intersection-- there's
some overlap over here.
So if you would
like to write out
the different areas
over here, what
they were equal to, well, this
is everything that is in M,
but we exclude what is in E.
So you write it M backslash E.
This part over here
is the intersection
of-- this maybe is a little
bit too small-- so this is
the intersection of both sets.
And over here we have
everything that's
in E but excluding what is in
M. So if you just write out
the cardinalities of
the different sets
that we're interested
in-- so we would
like to compute the cardinality
of the union of M and E.
So let's have a look
how the cardinality of M
itself can be computed.
Well, if you use the sum rule
which says that we can simply
add the two disjoint
sets that make up set M--
we can count each of
those cardinality--
so we have M consisting of this
part, which is M excluding E,
plus the part that is right
here which is the intersection.
So we use the sum
rule and conclude
that we have the sum
of everything that's
in M excluding E
plus the cardinality
of the intersection.
Now, for set E we can do
something completely similar.
So we will have
everything that's
in E excluding what
is in M. And then
we still have the intersection.
Now we are interested in the
union of the sent M and E.
And now we need to add
this one this one and this
once together.
So what do we see?
We see that this is
actually equal to everything
that is in M but not
in E, everything that
is in their intersection,
plus everything
that's in E but not in M.
So we have these equations
that we can directly derived
from the sum rule.
And, well, now we can
see here that if we
are going to simply add-- that's
what the sum rule would say--
simply add the
cardinality of M and of E,
well, if we add
those two together,
we will count the
intersection double.
So we'll need to cancel that
because it's only counted once
in the union.
So if we combine those three
over here-- those three
equations-- then we can conclude
that this counts the set
M intersecting with E twice.
So we have that
the union is really
equal to the cardinality
of M plus that
of E minus their intersection.
Now we can generalize this.
And we will give
one more example
where we have three sets and it
will give the general equation.
So suppose you have
three sets now.
Like one, another one,
and another one over here.
So we have M, E, and,
say, the set S. Well,
let's have a look how many
times these different areas--
they're all disjoint--
how many times they
are counted when me add the
three cardinalities together.
So we have M plus
the cardinality of E
plus the cardinality
of S. Well, if you
do that then we count
this area exactly
once because it's in M, this
area we count once because it's
in M and another time because
it's in E-- so it's twice--
this particular area
is only counted once
in this sum over here.
And similarly, we have two
times over here, two times here,
and one times over here.
And this intersection
of all of the three,
well, it's counted when
we count elements in M
but also when we
count elements in E
and also when we
count elements in S.
So this is counted three times.
So let's have a look.
It seems like we want to
do exactly the same as what
we did before.
We like to subtract an
intersection of M and S.
That's this part.
It cancels the double
counting in this area, right?
We can subtract this
intersection such that this
part is cancelled.
The double counting
here is canceled.
And similarly, we
want to subtract
the intersection between
E and S which would
eliminate this double counting.
But now we can see that
we start to subtract
too much because this central
area here will be-- well,
it's part of each of
those intersections
so it's actually eliminated.
All of it is subtracted.
So let's create
the same diagram.
But now when we count the sum
of all those intersections--
so we have the
intersection of M intersect
with E, the intersection
of M with S,
and we also want to figure
out how many times elements
are counted in the set
E intersects with S.
So let's have a look.
Well, this area here
is counted zero times.
It's not part of any
of these intersections
because it-- this part is
only in M and not in S or E.
So this is counted zero times.
And here we have the same.
Well, this part over
here is exactly once
in this intersection
between those two sets.
It's not in this one so
this is counted once.
So we have by symmetry
that for all the others.
This area, however, is in both
this intersection as well as
this one and also this one.
So it's counted three times.
So now we can easily start to
combine all these together.
And you can see, if we take
this sum and we subtract this,
then the middle
area is cancelled.
So we have to still add the
intersection of the three sets.
The intersection of
M, E and S together.
So in a formula that
would look like this.
So we are interested
in the union.
And this can now be
written as, well,
the sum of the cardinalities
of the individual sets.
And we subtract
the intersections
that we have up there.
So M intersect E
minus M intersect
with S and minus E
intersect with S.
Now we have eliminated-- if
you look at this Venn diagram
over here-- this
diagram over here--
we've eliminated everything
that's in the middle area.
So we still need to add
intersection-- everything that
is counted in the intersection
of M, E, as well as S.
So we have this equation.
And now you can see why we call
this the inclusion-exclusion
principle.
Here we include all the
elements in M, E and S.
Now we have to exclude
what we counted too much.
So we have exclusion over here.
And now we, again, have
to include some stuff
because we excluded too much.
And then we keep
on going like this.
So, in general, we get
the following theorem
that says that, if you
look at the cardinalities--
of the cardinality of the union
of a whole bunch of sets--
say we have n sets-- then this
is actually equal to-- well,
we first include the sums of all
the individual cardinalities.
Which is from I equals 1 to n
cardinality of Ai minus-- now
we have to, again,
we have to eliminate
all the double counting-- so
we look at every pair of sets
indexed by i1 and i2.
And we look at
their intersection
and we take that out
using this minus sign.
We exclude this.
And we continue like this.
So we add now-- because
we have excluded too much,
we have to include
some more-- we
look at all triples of sets
indexed by i1, i2-- oops--
and i3.
And now we look at the
intersection of those sets.
And we continue like
this all the way
until we look at the very last
intersection that you can have,
which is intersection
of all the sets.
And it depends on whether
n is even or add whether we
have to include or exclude it.
So we have a minus 1
to the power n plus 1.
And then we have the
intersection of all of these.
Now, we can write this out
in a more elegant formula
where we just put all this
what I wrote here in a sum.
And then it looks like this.
It's the sum over k
equals 1 to n minus 1
to the power k plus 1.
So depends whether
k is even or odd
whether we do an inclusion
or an exclusion in this sum.
And we look at all the subsets
that our subsets of the index
set 1 up to n such that the
cardinality of the set S
is equal to k.
And now we need to look at
the cardinality of all--
of the intersection of all the
sets that are indexed by S.
So that's-- so I run-- I put i--
so do the intersection of all i
in S of the sets Ai.
So this general formula is the
inclusion-exclusion principle.
And this is the way
how we can think
about it how to derive it.
Of course, this is not a proof.
But you could do this
yourself by using induction.
And you can use induction on n.
So that's a pretty
straightforward exercise.
OK.
So let's give an example.
Let's do that over here.
You will have a problem that's
similar on the problem set.
And it's goes like this.
You would like to know how
many permutations are there
with a special property.
So how many permutations
do I have of the set 0,
1 all the way up to 9.
So all the digits.
And that have consecutive--
so I put this in brackets just
to clarify-- so consecutive
either a 4 and a 2 right next
to one another.
So remember, a permutation
is a sequence that has each
of those digits exactly once.
And I like to count
those permutations that
have a 4 and a 2 next to
one another in this way.
So we have 4, 2.
Or the permutation may
have a 0, 4 or a 6, 0.
So I'm very curious, how
many permutations do I have?
And I'm going to use this
principle that I just
described.
So how do we need to
go ahead with this?
Well, this-- so I'm interested
in the permutations that have
a 4 and 2 next to one another.
So that could be my
first set, say, M.
And then I have
a set that I want
to count that has the 0 and
the 4 next to one another.
That could be my
E. And the S could
be those permutations that
have the 6 and a 0 next to one
another.
So then I would like to
use that rule over here.
So I would also need to count
all the intersections and so
on.
So let's do this.
Let me first give an example
of such a permutation.
So for example, I could
have the permutation
that is the sequence 7,
2, 5, 6, 0, and the 4,
for example, 3, 5, 1 and 9.
So I have all the digits
that are in the-- contained
in the set.
And I see that, actually,
this particular permutation
has a 6 and a 0
next to one another.
So it's in this particular--
the set of permutations
that have a 6 and a 0.
I can also see it
has a 0 and a 4.
So it's also in the set of
permutations that have a 0
and a 4 next to one another.
OK.
So now I'm going to define
these different sets
and then we're going to
start counting these.
And this is the type
of counting that you're
doing in this problem set.
And the intuition
that you create
by doing that you
can use later on when
we study probability theory.
OK.
So let's define the set P4,
2 as all the permutations
that have-- so it's the set
of permutations with 4, 2.
And similarly, we have P0, 4
which is the same thing but now
with 0, 4.
P6, 0, the set of full
permutations with 6, 0.
So let's have a look at what
the sizes of an individual
set of permutations.
How can we do this?
So let's have a look at the
size of, say, this one, P60.
Well, what kind of trick can
I do in order to count this?
So we have learned a
few rules last time.
And what I would like
to do is, well, this
is a slightly more
complex structure,
so I would like to
map this to a set
by means of a bijection
That will be great.
Then to do some
kind of other sets
that is easy to count for me.
So then, by the
bijection rule, I
will be able to figure out what
the cardinalities of this set.
So the trick here is to
find such a bijection.
And the idea is that you could
actually treat the 6 and the 0
as one unique symbol.
So let's see how it works.
So what I could do is I
can have, from the set
of-- from P60-- so all
the permutations that
have 6 and a 0 next
to one another-- I
can find a bijection to the
permutations of the set that
have 6, 0 as a single symbol.
And then I have all the other
symbols, all the other digits.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 7, 8, and 0.
So let's have an example of--
we have one up here, actually.
So how would I map this?
This would be mapped
according to that definition.
To 7, 2, 5.
And now I combine 6 and 0 into
one symbol in my sequence.
And then I have the rest.
4, 3, 5, 1, and 9.
Now this is easy for
me to count, right?
So this is a bijection.
And by the bijection rule,
the cardinality of this set
is equal to the total number
of permutations on this set.
Now, this set has
exactly eight elements
so I know how many there are.
So I know that the cardinality
is equal to 8 factorial.
Because there are 8 factorial
permutations on sets of size 8.
We saw that last time.
So that's the trick or--
AUDIENCE: Nine.
PROFESSOR: Oh, is it nine?
Oh, yeah, you're right.
Great.
So this is 9.
And similarly, in the same way,
we can also count these, right?
We can treat 0, 4 as one
symbol or 4, 2 as one symbol.
So I also know that the
cardinalities of these
are also equal to 9 factorial.
Now, when I use the
inclusion-exclusion principle--
so now I've computed
those three,
essentially-- I need to
subtract their intersections.
So let's compute
the intersections.
And if you do that, we're going
to use the exact same trick.
So we're going to find the
bijection to permutations
of a set of symbols.
And we just have
to specify those.
So let's do this together
and take, for example,
the intersection
of P42 with P60.
So what kind of a
bijection could I have?
So it will be all-- to
all the permutations
on what kind of a set?
So I use the exact
same trick here.
So I'm going to treat 4 and 2
as one symbol and 6, 0 as one
symbol.
So I have 4, 2, 6, 0 and
then all the other digits.
So it's the 1, 3,
5, 7, 8, and 9.
You can count that
this number is 8.
So by the bijection
rule, we have
that the cardinality
of this intersection
is equal to 8 factorial.
And we continue
like this to compute
all the other intersections.
And they do look a little
bit different sometimes.
So for example, if I
have 6, 0 and P 0, 4--
so let me define the permutation
first-- or the bijection first.
So how do we do this one?
Any suggestions?
So what kind of a set can
I find a permutation to?
If I look-- so over here I have
a permutation in which 6 and 0
are next to one another.
But this is also a
permutation in which 0 and 4
are next to one another.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So 3, 6, 0 and 4 is one
symbol because permutation
is right in here has a 6
and 0 next to one another.
And the 0 should also be next to
the 4 because it's in this set
as well.
So we know that every
permutation in here
has a sub sequence of 6,
0, 4 next to one another.
So we can treat
this as one symbol.
And then we have
all the other ones.
And again, this is--
these are 8 elements.
So we have that also,
for this intersection,
the cardinality is equal,
by the bijection rule,
as the total number
of permutations
on a set of eight elements,
which is 8 factorial.
So for the last one, we
also have similar-- so
let me see which
one I need to do.
So I have 4, 2 and 0, 4.
Well, again, I do
the same trick.
Now I have a symbol that has--
well, the permutation here
has a 0 and a 4
next to one another,
and the 4 is next to a 2.
So I treat this as one symbol.
So if the permutations on
the set 0, 4, 2, and then
1, 3, 5, 7-- oh, and 6
as well-- 8 and nine.
So the cardinality of this set
is also equal to 8 factorial.
So now we still have to look
at the intersection of all
of those three in order to
use the inclusion-exclusion
principle.
And, well, the same trick
can be used over here.
So we look at the
intersection of P60 with P04
and the permutations that have
4 and 2 next to one another.
So what does that mean?
It means that the
permutation that's in here
has a 6, 0 and then
a 4 and then a 2.
So these are all the
permutations with a 6, 0, 4,
2 next to one another.
And this can map
easily to the sets
where we treat this
as one symbol-- 6042--
and then we have 1,
3, 5, 7, 8, and 9.
This set has seven elements, so
the intersection of these three
is equal to 7 factorial.
And now we can use the
inclusion-exclusion principle
using this over here.
And when we plug
everything in here,
we can see that the
intersection-- that the union--
when we count the union of P60
which P04 and P42 is actually
equal to 9 factorial for
these, 8 factorials for those,
and a 7 factorial for these.
So it's 3 times 9 factorial
minus 3 times 8 factorial
plus 1 times a 7 factorial.
So this is how we can use
inclusion-exclusion principle.
So this generalized
the sum rule.
And now we have a
whole set of rules
already discussed
since last time.
We continue with
the bookkeeper rule.
You have already seen
it during recitation
so I will only write
it out once more.
And all these rules
together we will then
use in a set of examples.
So what was the bookkeeper rule?
We have that-- so the
bookkeeper rule is,
if I have distinct copies of
letters-- so distinct copies
of letters l1, l2,
l3 and lk, well, then
the number of
sequences that have
exactly n1 letters
of the type l1
and n2 letters of the type
l2 and so on, well, we
can count those.
So sequences with n1 copies
of l1 and n2 copies of l2,
and then we continue like this
until we have nk copies of lk.
Well, we can count this.
So these copies can
be in an arbitrary
order in the sequence.
And we saw in recitation that
this can be written as n plus 1
plus n2 all the way
up to nk factorial.
And we divide out the product
that starts with n1 factorial
times n2 factorial
up to nk factorial.
And this we also can
write as what-- well,
this is actually the
definition of what we call
the multinomial coefficient.
So you've already seen the
binomial coefficients, which
is a special case of this one.
So we write this as
n1 plus up to nk.
And then we have
n1, n2, and we just
repeat all of those in here.
If we have k equals 2, then we
get the binomial coefficient.
And if k equals this 2,
we also often just forget
about the last term.
So we would get
expressions that look
like this, which is really
equal to nk comma n minus k.
OK.
So this is some-- these
are some definitions.
And we can apply
this bookkeeper rule.
For example, last time in the
lecture we were talking about
the number of bit sequences
of length 16 with four 1's.
We wanted to count this because
we found out that if you want
to select 12 donuts
of five varieties,
we can find a mapping of
bijection towards this set
of bit sequences with
12 0's and four 1's.
So the bookkeeper rule will tell
us exactly how many there are.
And that's the most basic
example, essentially,
of this way of counting.
So what do we have?
So the number of bit sequences
of length 16 and with four
1's-- well, is exactly equal
to, according to this rule,
as length 16 and we need to
choose four 1's out of these
16.
And it's the
binomial coefficients
where we choose four
out of the 16 symbols.
And this is equal to 16
factorial divided by 4
factorial times 12 factorial.
Now we often also denote
the following rule--
we sort of identify
as a special case.
We say that the number of
k elements-- of k element
subsets-- of an n element set
is actually equal to n choose k.
So this is an important
rule to remember
which will occur many times.
OK.
A theorem that we can have
derived from all this stuff
is what we call the
binomial theorem.
So we'll quickly go over that.
The binomial theorem says
that, for all integers n--
positive integers n-- we have
a plus b to the power n equals
to the sum where we
take k from 0 to n
and then we have the
binomial where we
have this expression over here.
We choose k out of n
and we choose, say, k
times b in this expression.
I will explain in a
moment by an example.
And n minus k ace.
And this is the theorem.
And I will just
give an example just
to show how we can
think about this.
So let me do that over here.
So if you take n
equals to 2, then we
can see that we get all the
combinations, essentially,
of a and b of length 2.
So you have a times a, a times
b, b times a, and b times b.
So what do we see?
We see a squared plus ab
plus ba plus b squared.
Now we see that these have 1
times an a and 1 times a b.
This one has 2 times an a
and this one has 2 times a b.
And this combines together
as a squared plus 2 times
ab plus b squared.
Now, if you have n equals 3--
so we have a plus b to the power
3-- you will get all
the different products,
all the different terms,
that add up to this,
are all the kinds of
combinations of a's and b's.
So for example, we have three
a's-- so 3 times a-- but it can
also have a squared times b
plus aba plus b a squared.
And those have exactly two
times an a and one times a b.
I can now look at
all the others--
so I may have two times
the b and one times the a.
So what our those?
We have a times b squared
plus bab plus b squared a.
So I count these
as the same, right?
They each have the
same number of b's.
Two times the b and
one times the a.
And then, finally, I
have b to the power 3
which counts three times the b.
So these are all the
possible terms that I have.
There are eight in total.
One, two, three, four,
five, up to eight.
And that fits, right?
Because I can have a
choice of an a and a b.
And I do that three times.
So 2 times 2 times
2 is equal to 8.
So I have eight terms.
And I can group them together
by taking a to the power 3
plus 3 times a squared
b plus 3 times-- and now
I have b squared a-- and
finally, b to the power 3.
So what do we see here?
How many terms are their
that have exactly two times
an a and one times a b?
Well, it's like we have a
set of three elements, right?
Or three positions.
And I like two of
them to be an a.
So I choose two out of
those three to be an a.
So I use this subset rule
to count how many times I
see the same term back.
So let's write this
out so that is-- so
the number of terms
that have k times an a,
and we have, say, n
minus k times a b.
So how many terms do I have?
Well, that is the length
of-- so the number of-- oops.
Change that.
So it's the number
of length n sequences
that have the
following property.
That these have k a's
and n minus k b's.
And that's easy to count.
Which is equal to what
we have done here before.
We have the binomial n choose k.
And that, if you plug
that in over here,
then we get this particular sum.
So it is-- this is
the binomial theorem.
Very famous.
And now we're going
to use all this stuff
to count some poker hands.
So we have come to this
part of the lecture.
So we're going to do
a bunch of examples
that are similar
to some of those
that you will see
in the problem set.
And then at the end
we go and continue
with some-- with a
different proof technique.
So let's first define
a deck of cards
because that's what we
are going to use now.
So for this type of
problems, we will
use a deck which is
actually a set of 52 cards.
And a card itself
actually has a suit.
And the suit can
be something that
looks like this, which
is called spades.
S of spades.
We have another symbol
which is this, hearts.
And we will have clubs
and we have diamonds.
And besides a suit, a
card also has a value.
And the values are arranged from
2, 3, 4, all the way up to 10.
Then we have a special
symbol-- special value--
which is called the Jack.
We've got a Queen and a
King and finally the Ace.
And in total, we have
13 possible values.
So you can see that
we have four times,
because of four different
suits, 4 times 13
is 52 different cards
and that makes up a deck.
So we're going to look at hands.
And a hand is actually
a collection-- a set
of five cards.
So it's a subset of
the deck of five cards.
And we do not worry
about the order
of the cards in your hand.
They can be permuted,
if you want.
So the order's not important.
So it's a subset of five cards.
So how many hands do I have?
Well, how many ways
are there to choose
a subset of five cards
out of a deck of 52 cards?
Well, we can use
a subset through
and we get the
binomial 52 choose 5.
Which is, by the way, a lot so
let me write it out as well.
It's about 2 and 1/2 million.
So we are interested
in, when we play poker--
if you do that-- in
really good hands.
So we like four of
a kind, which means
that we have four cards that
actually have the same value.
Or we have cards
that-- hands that have
what we call a full house.
We will count those in a moment.
Or other kinds of combinations.
And the rarer the combination
is in your hand, the higher
or the better your hand
is, and the more likely
it is that you win
the poker game.
If you do not get left out.
All right.
So let's give an example
of a four of a kind.
So we're going to
compute those and we
will see that we need to do--
to use all the-- a combination
for all these rules.
OK.
So four of a kind
is the special hand
where we have four
of one kind of value.
Notice, by the way, that the
fifth card, because of this,
must have a different
value, right?
Because there are
only four cards
that have, say, the value eight.
Because there are only
four different suits.
So the fifth card
will ultimately
have a different value.
So as an example, we will have
the 8 of spades and then the 9
of diamonds and all the
other 8's-- the 8 of diamonds
and the 8 of hearts and,
say, the 8 of clubs.
And how do we count
these types of hands?
We're going to look
for a representation
of how can you represent
such hands, such objects?
So we have to count a
special type of object,
a special kind of poker hand.
And in order to do
that, we're going
to look for a way to
represent these objects
and in such a way that we
can count them very easily.
And that's really
the trick in order
to solve these kinds
of counting problems.
So the representation
that we have here is--
well, we can choose--
first of all,
we can choose the value of the
four kinds-- of the four cards.
So how many choices do I have?
Well, I got any choice.
There are 13 different
values so I have 13 choices.
So that's easy.
Secondly, I can choose the
value of the extra card.
So how many choices
do I have here?
Well, the four of a kind already
eliminates one kind of value
completely.
Right?
So I have any of the
other values is possible.
Is equally likely, even.
So I have 12 choices.
And, lastly, I can represent--
I need to still represent
the suit of the extra card.
So I also want to know the
suit of the extra card.
And how many choices do I have?
Well, I can choose
any of those four.
So that's four.
So, essentially, what
we constructed here
is a mapping by using
this representation.
And the mapping tells
us-- is as follows.
Let's keep this up.
So the mapping goes from poker
hands-- from card-- from hands
to-- from hands with four of
a kind to this representation.
So let's write it out.
So we have four of a kind.
And then we have a
function-- a mapping
f-- that goes to
this representation.
We will have the first
entry-- the value 1
and the value 2
and then a value 3.
So for example, if you
take this hands of cards,
well, the first one, we see that
the four of a kind has value 8.
The value of the second card is
the 9 of the 9 diamonds cards.
So we have 9.
And finally, the suit
that I need to select for,
the extra card is diamonds.
So this is an example.
And now we know, because
this is a bijection,
we know that the number of
hands with four of a kind
is equal to all these
types of sequences,
all these types of
sequences that can--
that are chosen according
to this representation.
Well, we have 13 choices
for the first value.
And given this first
value, we have 12 choices
for the second value.
And given those two, I have four
choices for the very last entry
in this sequence.
So this is the generalized
product rule that I'm using.
So we see that the number of
sequences is equal to 13 times
12 times 4.
Turns out this is equal to 624.
Well, if you divide it
over total number of cards.
So how did we do this?
This is the generalized
product rule.
If you divide this number
of the total number of cards
we could get the fraction
of one over about 4,000.
So it's really rare that
you get four of a kind.
So it's a really good hand.
OK.
Let's do a few more of these.
We also like to know how
many full houses there are.
A full house is a special hand.
It has three cards of one value
and two cards of another value.
So how many are there?
So again, we are going to
use the exact same principle.
We're going to find
a representation
of this type of hand.
So we have three cards of one
value and two cards of another.
So for example, we may have
the hands that contain,
say, three cards with value 2.
A 2 clubs, a 2 spades,
and also a 2 diamonds.
And, say, a Jack club
and a Jack of diamonds.
And another example could be,
say, a 5 of diamonds and a 5
of hearts, 5 of clubs, 7 of
hearts, and also a 7 of club.
So now you can see that it's
very easy to represent this.
Right?
We can start grouping
things together.
We can say, represent
this by first
taking the value of the
three cards that I have here.
So it's 2.
Then I want to indicate in a
second term in my sequence--
in my representation-- which
suits did I use over here?
Well, I used clubs,
spades and diamonds.
So it's a set club,
And now I also have a pair.
Like, two cards
with the same value.
What's the value?
It's Jack.
And what are the suits
associated to these?
Well, clubs and the diamonds.
So I have not yet for-- given
you the formal definition
of the representation,
but you can
see that you could do
something like this.
So this is often how we start
out on a piece of paper.
You try to do something
and hopefully it works.
So we have-- here we have
diamonds, hearts, and clubs.
And then we have--
finally we have two cards
with the same value 7.
And they have the hearts
and clubs as suits.
OK.
So the representation
is defined as follows.
It just started out with a first
entry in my representation.
And this is going to be
the value of the triple.
So how many choices do
we have for this value?
Well, I can choose any of
the 13 possible values.
So I have 13 choices.
And the second part is
the suits of the triple.
Well, I have to choose
a subset of the four
possible suits of size three.
So I need to have a subset
of size three out of the four
possible suits.
And that will give me the
proper representation.
So how many choices do I
have for such a subset?
Well, there's three
elements out of four.
So we can use the subset
rule and see that this has
4 choose 3 equals four choices.
Then the last part is
to value of the pair
that I have of the two cards
that are having the same value.
Now, how many choices
do I have here?
Well, I have to be a
little bit careful, though.
I just want to make sure that
I do the right reasoning here.
I know that there's still--
because I chose a triple
of cards of the same
value-- for example,
over here I chose all these
2's-- but I still have one card
in my deck which has a 2.
Actually, here I've chosen
clubs, spades and diamonds.
So the one that is missing
is the 2 of hearts.
So I could possibly
choose the 2 of hearts.
But wait a minute.
If I choose the 2 of hearts,
how can I make a pair?
That's not possible, right?
Because I've already
chosen all the other 2's
so there's no other 2
to match to find a pair.
So I actually cannot choose this
particular value of this triple
for the pair.
But all the other
values are possible.
So I have 12 choices.
One less than the one that I've
already chosen for the triple.
Now, and then similarly, I
can choose suits of the pair.
And how many choices do I have?
Well, look at every
possible subset
that I can have of size
two out of the four suits.
So I use the subset rule
and find that this is 4
choose 2 which is equal to 6.
So now we're going to multiply
all of these together.
We use the generalized
product rule again.
So we have found a mapping
from hands with a full house
to these types of
representations--
to this representation.
And this mapping is bijective.
So the number of full house
is exactly equal to the number
of these representations.
And by the generalized
product rule,
I can choose the first entry
of such a sequence in 13 ways.
The second one, given the
first one, in four ways.
This one I can choose
in 12 ways given I've
already chosen my triple.
And so on.
So by the generalized
product rule,
I know now that the
product of those four
is equal to the total
number of full house hands.
So how much is that?
It's 13 times 4 choose 3
times 12 times 4 choose 2.
And this turns out
to be equal to 3,744.
Which is a factor six bigger
than a four of a kind.
So it's much more likely
that you get one of those.
And that's the reason
why four of a kind
has more worth-- is worth
much more than a full house.
So let's do another example,
a hand with two pairs,
and see whether we can continue
this type of reasoning.
It's going pretty well.
And maybe we can
do the same thing.
We'll see that, in
counting, you really
have to take a lot of care.
So maybe you can
already see what's
happening when I start reasoning
in the exact same way as
before.
So let me first define
what I want to count.
It's a hand that have
exactly two pairs.
So what does that mean?
It means that there is-- that
we have two cards of one value
and another two cards
of another value.
So let's start out as before.
We're going to write
out a representation
and see whether we
can do this properly.
So we're going to use
the exact same technique.
So first of all,
we're going to choose
the value of the first pair.
Now, how many ways
can I do this?
Well, I can do this in 13 ways.
Any possible value is possible.
I need to choose the
suits of the first pair.
And how many ways can I do this?
Well, I use the same
techniques as over here,
so it's any possible way
to choose two elements out
of a set of four which
represent all the suits.
So that's 4 choose 2.
Then, three, we're
going to choose
the value of the second pair.
Well, that's easy because the
second pair, by definition,
must have a different value
than the one in the first pair.
Well, I've already
chosen one value
so I have 12 choices left.
So that's no problem.
And now we can continue
and do the same thing.
So we're going to count the
number of suites that are
possible for the second pair.
And it's the same number as
we have for the first pair.
So we have a number of
suits of the second pair.
Again, we need to
choose two suits out
of the complete set of suits,
which has four possibilities.
So it's 4 choose 2.
And now we can have still a
choice for the last cards.
We have now two pairs.
We still have a fifth card.
The fifth card also has a value.
Actually, I did
not write it down,
but if we talk about
a hand with two pairs,
we mean two cards of one value,
two cards of another value,
and the fifth card-- the extra
card-- has yet another value.
Because otherwise you
would have a full house
and we have already
counted those.
OK.
So value of the extra card.
Well, I've chosen
already two values.
The one for the first pair,
the one of the second pair,
so there are 11 choices left.
And finally, I can choose
a suit of the extra card.
Well, I have one out of
four choices for my suit.
So again we can use the
generalized product rule
and we can say that we have
30 choices for my first entry
in my presentation.
Right?
For the first choice.
Then given the first
choice, I have 4 choose
2 choices for the second.
And then 12 choices
for the third
if I've already
chosen the first two.
And so on.
So I can use the
generalized product rule
and count these representations.
So the number of
representations is actually
equal to 13 times 4
choose 2 times 12 times
4 choose 2 again times
11 times 4 choose 1.
So is this a number of
the hands with two pairs?
So this seems to be
pretty reasonable.
But can you see something that
has happened here that we also
saw actually last lecture?
Like, do I know for sure
that the hands with two pairs
is-- well, that are this
number of hands with two pairs.
What do I need to check in order
to make sure that that is true?
Well, I need to make-- I
need to prove, essentially,
that this representation
is actually
bijection from the
hands with two pairs
to this types of sequences.
So is that true?
Or does this mapping have
a different property?
Any ideas?
Yeah?
Over there.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No?
You don't want to answer?
OK.
Well, let me-- when we talked
about the chess game last time,
or with the rooks,
we could essentially
had two rooks that we
could choose and put them
on different positions with no
shared rows or shared columns.
And here we have two pairs with
no shared suit-- with no shared
values.
But what can we do?
We can actually interchange
the first and the second pair.
So as an example, we can
have two representations
that map to the same hand.
So let me give an example.
So for example, suppose
you choose the value
3 for the first
pair and then I'm
choosing the set diamonds and
clubs for the suits of those.
And say the second pair is a
queen of diamonds and hearts.
And finally, I have
an ace of clubs.
Well, this would be a
proper sequence according
to this representation.
But this maps to a
hand that does also
map to if we interchange the
first and the second pair.
We can also start off with
the queen for the first pair
and we have diamonds and hearts.
And we have three for the second
pair with diamonds and clubs.
And then we finally have
the fifth card which
is the same, the ace of clubs.
Now these map to
exactly the same hand.
We just need to change the
first and the second pair.
Now this is a kind of problem
or a mental sort of confusion
that very easily happened.
This is a rather easy
example where you can see it.
But if you do
counting, we really
have to take care that
we make sure that each
of the sequences in
this representation
are really represented by,
say, one hand, in this case,
with two pairs.
But how can we remedy this?
It turns that we can-- by
interchanging these two pairs,
these two sequences are
the only two sequences
that map to the same hand.
So we know that this
is not a bijection
but it is a 2-to-1 mapping.
So now we can choose-- we
can use the division rule.
And by the division
rule we now know
that the number of
hands with two pairs
is actually equal to this whole
thing over here divided by 2
because we have a
2-to-1 function.
Now, this is really
something that
is pretty disturbing
because we have
a near miss in our reasoning.
And therefore, it
is important to keep
in mind the following
guidelines when we do counting.
It's very important
to, first of all, check
whether it's truly a bijection.
And you need to know how many
sequences or maps to the same--
to the same hand.
So the guidelines
are as follows.
They're pretty
straightforward actually.
First of all, if
we have a function
f that maps from A to
B, then we would really
like to check very carefully
whether the number-- what
is the number of
elements of A that are
mapped to each element of B?
So we check how many to one
of a mapping this really is.
And after this we will then
apply the division rule.
It's very important
to check this.
But very often, we're
making mistakes.
For example, right now
I'm doing some research
and I've been
counting something.
Turns out it-- if I
use a different method
to count the same thing
I get a different answer.
So I made a mistake somewhere.
So that's the second guideline.
So what you want to
do is you want to try
and solving a problem
in multiple ways.
So try solving a problem
in a different way.
And especially with counting
this is very helpful.
So this will lead
to an extra check.
So we will do that for
this particular example.
And it generally
would always like
to find multiple ways to
prove things, I would say,
because at least you want
to have multiple-- maybe not
a complete proof but
subparts of proofs--
you may want to find different
ways why that is true.
So that's how I usually
do my proofing of things.
So let's find a second way
to count this over here,
to do the double check.
So we're going to create a
different representation that
should actually
lead to a bijection.
So I want to find a
representation that's
a bijection, a 1-to-1 mapping.
So how do we do this?
I can-- let me see where I am.
OK.
So what I could do
is, first of all,
I can choose the values
of the two pairs.
So in this case, I have
the values 3 and the queen.
So how many choices do I have?
Well, I can choose
two out of 13 choices.
Secondly, I'm going to describe
the suit of the smaller
pair which is uniquely defined
because they have two values.
One is smaller and the
suit of the smaller
pair I can choose by taking one
out the four-- two out of four
choices because I need to choose
two suits for the smaller pair.
For the larger
pair, I do the same.
And I get 4 choose 2.
Now, again, I have the
value of the extra card.
And I have 11 choices.
I have already chosen two so
there are 11 choices left.
And finally, the suit
for the extra card
can be done in 4 choose 1 ways.
So if you multiply
those together,
we get 13 times 12 divided by 2.
And then we get times 4 choose 2
times 4 choose 2 times 11 times
4 choose 1.
And we can see that
that's exactly the same
as this whole
product divided by 2.
We actually have a bijection.
This particular representation
is a 1-to-1 mapping.
So it's always good
to find a second way
to prove the same result.
OK.
Let me do one more.
Let's do that over here.
Just to make sure that you
really understand this stuff,
I'm going to count hands
that have each suit in it.
So I want to count the
hands with every suit.
So as an example, I can
have, say, the 7 of diamonds,
the King of clubs, the 3 of
diamonds, the Ace of hearts,
and the 2 of spades.
Why is this a proper hand?
Because I can see the diamonds,
the clubs, the hearts,
and the spades.
So I have a hand in which
every suit is represented.
So what do I do for
my representation?
Well, I can have the
values of each suit
and I assign a specific
order to those.
So I want to represent for
the diamonds and the clubs
and the heart and the spade.
I want to find out what
values do I really have.
So values of each suit in the
order D, C, hearts and spades.
And how many ways do I have?
Well, I have 13
values for the 7,
I have 13 values for
the King-- for this one,
for this value, 13 values
for that one and 13
values for this one.
So that is pretty
straightforward.
Now, we still have
the extra card.
And the extra card
has a suit which
I can do in four ways
because of four choices.
And finally, it
also has a value.
And the value is-- it's
actually-- so how much is this?
Can this be 13?
Are there 13 values?
No, not really, right?
Because for each possible
given suit that I've chosen,
I already chose a
value before when
I chose a value for the
suit that I did over here.
So for example, this
one cannot be the 7,
it has to be something else.
There are 12 choices.
If I would have chose
a different suit,
for example hearts,
then I would not
be able to choose the Ace
because I already have chosen
the Ace in the first step.
So I have 12 possibilities here.
So this is not 13.
You may want to
check that again.
So now let's give the
representation for this one.
So I can have diamonds, clubs--
so let's see, in the order
of diamonds, clubs.
So I have the 7,
I have a King, I
have for hearts I have an
Ace, for spades I have a 2.
Then I have the suit for the
extra card which is a diamonds.
And then a value which is a 3.
Now we are going
to check according
to our guidelines over here.
We're going to check
the number of elements
that are-- the number
of sequences that
map to the same hand over here.
So is this a bijection?
It's not, right?
So why is this not a bijection?
Well, we can also have
the following situation
where we swap the 3 diamonds
and the 7 diamonds around.
So we choose the
3 for the diamonds
and then we have the
King, the Ace and the 2.
then we have the fifth card
which is also diamonds,
but now it's the 7.
Well, this one also maps
to this particular hand.
So we have a 2-to-1 mapping.
And we conclude that the
total number of hands,
where every suit is represented,
is 13 to the power 4 times
4 times 12 by the
generalized product rule.
And now by the division rule,
we have to still divide by 2.
So that's the total number.
OK.
So now we come to
combinatorial proofs.
So this is a new
proof technique.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to count a set
in two different ways.
And that will lead to a
combinatorial equation.
So the whole idea is as follows.
So let me give an example first.
So for a combinatorial
proof, for example,
suppose I have n
shirts and I want
to choose-- I want to keep k
and I want to trash n minus k.
So how do I count the number
of choices that I have?
Well, I can choose, out of n,
I can choose the k keepers.
But I also can count
it in a different way.
I can also count
this as how many ways
I can select the trashers.
So there are n minus k out of
n shirts that I will trash.
So there are two different
ways to count the same choices
that I have.
So we have an
equation over here.
And you already know this
one because by the definition
of the binomial
coefficient, we have
that this is equal to this.
And so it's pretty
straightforward.
It's equal to this
one over here.
But the idea is that
we're going to count
a set in two different ways.
So another example is where
we have the following.
We choose a team of k elements.
Of k elements out
of-- oh, actually, I'm
talking about a team.
I was talking about
students here.
Of k students.
Out of n students.
Now, how many ways
can I do this?
Well, n choose k, right?
Well, there is a way to
count this differently.
I could also say, well, let's
first count the total number
of ways in which I choose k
students that includes Bob.
So let's do that.
So Bob is one of the
students, and if I
count the number
of teams with Bob,
how many choices do I have?
I choose Bob.
I still need to choose k minus
1 students out of the remaining
n minus 1 students.
So I have taken out Bob.
So there are n minus
1 students left
and I still need to
choose k minus 1 students.
The other possibility is that
we have teams that-- in which
Bob is not represented.
So now we need to
choose k students out
off all the students minus Bob.
So we have n minus 1 choose k.
So by the sum rule, we can
just add those two together
and that should be equal
to all the possibilities
to choose team of k students.
So what do I see?
I see that n minus 1 choose k
minus 1 plus n minus 1 choose
k should be equal to--
well, before I counted it
as this-- so it should
be equal to n choose k.
And this is called
Pascal's Identity.
And the general idea is is
that we do the following.
So we are actually counting
a set in two different ways.
That's what we did so far.
And when you solve
these types of problems,
the difficulty is that you
will need to define the set S.
So usually you
get a problem, you
need to prove some
equation like this.
So you define a set S.
That's the hard part of it.
Then we are going to show
that the cardinality of S
is some number n,
say, in one way.
So we have one
method to do this.
By counting.
And we will show that S is also
equal to some other number--
like, in this case,
we had one number
and this was my second
one-- also by counting.
And then we can
conclude that n--
so we conclude that n equals m.
So we're almost done
because I'm going
to prove to you a very simple
equation using this technique.
But it is not as trivial as
the one that we saw just now.
What we do now is the following.
We want to prove a
theorem that says
that if a sum r is 0 all
the way up to n, then,
if you take the product of the
following binomial coefficients
n choose r times 2n
choose n minus r,
this is equal to 3n choose n.
We need to prove this.
So we need to find
the proper set.
So how can we think about it?
Well, the idea is
that we're probably
going to choose n elements
out of 3n elements.
We're going to do
it in a special way.
And so the proof
will be as follows.
We take S to be all the
subsets of n balls chosen
from a basket of n red
balls and 2n green balls.
And this will do the trick.
So how do we do this?
We're going to first choose
the red balls and then
the green balls.
So let's first count S
in the very easy way.
Well, I just choose n balls
out of a basket of 3n balls.
I don't care how many
green or red balls I have.
So I have really 3n
choose n choices.
This is the number of n element
subsets from a 3n element set.
So that's easy.
Now, we can also count
it in a different way.
We first of all wonder
about the number of subsets
with exactly r red balls.
So how many are there?
Well, we choose r red balls
so we have n red balls.
So we need to choose
r out of those.
Now, in total, I need
to choose n balls.
So I still need to choose
n minus r balls out
of the set of green balls.
I have 2n green balls.
I'm going to choose n minus
r green balls over here.
So these are the red balls
that I select and here
are the green balls.
Now we'll use the sum rule.
And I add all the
different possible subsets
with 0 red balls, with
1 red ball, 2 red balls,
all the way up to n red balls.
So essentially, I get the
sum by the sum rule of r 0
all the way up to n where I
count the number of subsets
with exactly r red balls.
So that means I can choose
r out of the n red balls
and another n minus r out of
the 2n balls-- 2n green balls.
So now we equate
those two together
and that proves the theorem.
So the really hard part
in this type of proofs
is that you need some creativity
to find and define that set S
and see how that would work.
And the way to do that usually
is to look at this equation
and then say, oh,
wait a minute, I'm
going to talk about sets because
I choose n out of 3n over here.
So out of 3n elements.
And maybe I can
divide up the sets
in some kind of specific choice.
So tomorrow during
recitation you
will also see
combinatorial proof.
Thank you.